all right ladies and gentlemen here on
the gamespot stage at e3 2015 so I'm
beginning to fight my treat Fighter 5 is
on stage now joining me Matt from Capcom
and then we've got PR raag and K Brad
from Team EG some professional Street
Fighter players gentlemen welcome to the
couch welcome to the stage house III
going oh it's going absolutely fantastic
man this is the first time we've been
able to have people have some hands-on
time with Street Fighter 5 uh-huh the
reception has been fantastic lots of
really cool street fighter related
activities going on at our booth so yeah
it's been a good incredible III
absolutely and you guys have
photographers taking over at your booth
you've got this incredible set up it's
like at all these cameras align in a row
people kind of do like fighting poses
with people dressed up like ryu and chun
li yeah and it pretty awesome full 3d
photo man and like people been going ham
we got some cosplayers out there super
super fun you guys got to get in there
next yeah I'll be damned all right all
right ah so you want to punch for you
yeah you want a bug-free area yeah uh
you guys are setting up to get into a
match right here with some of the new
characters but Matt yet at the press
conferences earlier this week you guys
review you guys have got birdie on the
scene and cami yeah Fighter 5 yeah man
we're now up to six playable characters
birdie was definitely kind of our
surprise announcement for the roster I
don't think anyone really saw him coming
haven't seen bad scene birdie around for
a little bit yeah I the last time you
saw him was the Alpha series we did like
to come up with this character roster we
did a lot of research birdie wasn't
necessarily very highly requested by the
fans but we had such a cool character
design and a concept that fit really
well in street fighter 5 that's why we
decided to go yeah part of it's got to
be you know considering what the fans
want but you guys also have to build a
balanced roster you know you have to get
a variety of styles in there and
different sort of I you know a
complementary fighting styles and
matchups that are going to be exciting
right oh yeah definitely um try try
using a guest login I did okay you're
good okay we're gonna sit on a seesaw a
live match here so it's just a sec but I
I think these guys are going to get to
it soon but guys before you get into it
and you're fighting and you're actually
you're not taught you don't want to talk
give us a little background on your like
your professional careers what what do
you who's your main what what
tournaments have you done well in give
me something my name is PR balrog
basically I've been in the scene for
five years people consider me the
Japanese his killer oh yeah yes success
so my biggest tournaments have been evil
basically and capcom pro two were
actually last year i defeated i go woof
and capcom pro tour it was pretty big it
was pretty cool to Train another about
so yeah that I can say that's why my
biggest tournament school and who did
who's your who's your guy Barac Balrog
naturally same Brad what about you so
I've been playing since street fighter 4
first came out and then I got known
after I'd be infiltration at caesars
beatings and then my name just blew up
after that yeah and then i just i just
recently won the most recent major ECT
and jersey and i've been playing like
cami ever since you ah I have to play I
when I look at birdie birdies just like
such an ugly character so okay I can I
only can play like really like cool
characters or the really hot chicks you
know i'm saying i mean you're gonna have
to be looking in that character online i
know i have to look at that like Barbie
look at his chain looking that's going
on I don't look at that he licked this
chain again nice cool all right so
you're playing kami PR balrog you got
you on birdie you guys go ahead and jump
into a match here we'll see it in action
and Matt let's dig into some of the sort
of mechanic tweaks sort of stuff you're
bringing new to street fighter 5
definitely so the new core gameplay
mechanic behind street fighter 5 is the
variable system that's replacing focus
attacks from street fighter 4 what's
cool about the variable system is it
allows for a lot of variety and gameplay
and it allows every character that's put
into the game to have a very distinct
play style that's all their own we want
to stray away from clones we want to
make sure that every character and there
has a specific purpose now there's three
main things that you can do with the
variable system we have a newbie gauge
and the
first thing you can do is call the V
trigger that basically allows your
character to unleash their true floor
and it's either a powered up mode or a
powered up attack that can really change
the tide of battle very easy to execute
once your meter is entirely full you
just press heavy punch and heavy cake
poke at the same time real quick yeah
second gameplay mechanic is called V
skills every character has their own
unique v skill these are these are moves
that add a new layer of utility to the
character so it could be like a new
Perry or a new movement option those can
be used at any time requires 0 meter the
last piece of the variable system RV
reversals they're very similar to alkyl
counters we had back in the day if
you're under a lot of pressure you can
activate that and do a little bit of
damage and push your opponent away from
you so whole variable system to really
see it in action I can go and explain
how the different be triggers and be
skills work for the characters we have
here so for birdie his be skill he eats
a donut he has three different options
donut which makes him build meter pastor
okay he can throw a banana peel on the
ground which can trip your opponent or
all ready to take an energy drink and
then roll it across the screen to
projectile so sixty percent sixty-six
percent two out of three of his be
skills are littering yeah pretty much
yeah alright yeah he looks like that
kind of guy seems pretty classy what
about Cammy so Cammie her b school is
her spin knuckle so it helps her deal
with a projectile game you can bust it
out at any time it'll go through to
remove or I project all and allow her to
get in close now that kind of move to
sort of going through projectile through
move is stuff it as a novice
streetfighter Blair I feel like I have
no chance of ever executing but so you
guys but you know you're also your
design in the game not just for
high-level players like these guys but
also for novices and so you know you
mentioned earlier the you know the heavy
attack too heavy kick yeah if that's a
real easy way to execute these moves how
do you sort of balance the gamut of
players you guys are wanting to welcome
into street fighter 5 yeah definitely
finding that balance of making the game
still inviting to newcomers and not
being too overwhelming at the beginning
as well as taking care of our
professional players that really do this
for a living and make the game shine
is like one of our key focal points yeah
and the variable system was really
designed with that in mind we still do
have complex commands in Street writer
so there are still double fireball
motions to be able to execute your
critical art but novice players will be
able to use the variable system very
effectively just two button presses at
the same time and you get some pretty
astounding results do you ever wish you
could make like a street fighter and a
street fighter being like this is the
novice woman like just put these like
crazy complex things into like I like
high level professional play oh yeah I
mean trust me the amount of
conversations we've had about fighting
games and how to strike that balance has
been staggering with it is about every
concept has been discussed or was on the
table at some point alright so in street
fighter 5 got the V triggers and you got
that sort of fit the main shift it
supplies across all the characters
applies in any match I we saw them using
that some of those in the match here PR
bell rock out that match go for you I
think we're pretty cool yeah yeah pretty
good how are you guys finding the new
system you have get are you just sort of
getting familiar with it we sure we
still are getting familiar with it but
honestly for me I like a lot cuz I'm a
really aggressive player and I think the
game it caters to aggressive players
okay because it's really fast there's a
stun meter now we can see what we're
doing better it's faster I really I'm
really enjoying a lot what do you think
hey Brad how's it shaping up I like it
way better than I like a way better than
the r35 a four-engine because it cater
to people like ah me that was a whole
Niner so they get the game they call us
Oh Niners because we didn't play any of
the old game so we just jumped right in
the street by the floor okay so at the
beginning you know we abuse a lot of
cheap stuff you know like like when I be
infiltration no way was I better than
you know he just he just want evil the
guy is like world champion and then this
new kid that no i hears about he's a
world champion so thank you capcom hey
give it a good day right you know Thank
You captain all-forgiving read very
cheap character yes
take down the evo champion but on this
game I think this game is going to be
way more about like you have to be a
better player to win so I think I think
I really like the internist like in this
game and I think certainly one of the
big tests you got you mentioned it evo
coming up later this year but you guys
have a whole tournament circuit that
goes year round yeah so we're now in the
second season the Capcom pro two are
things are going absolutely incredible
half million dollars worth of prize
money that's more prize money than the
fighting game scene has ever seen yes
alam we basically double double the
number of spots that are available for
the capcom cups last year it was 16 this
year it's 32 16 premier events it's a
truly globally minded league we've
balanced out the number of events and
ranking points that are available in
each region so that every region has a
fair shot so it's equally balanced
between North America Europe Asia and we
have a couple in there for emerging
markets we're just getting started this
is only our second season street fighter
5 hasn't even come out yet so exciting
time to wait we expect to see some
pretty significant growth in the
fighting scene in the coming year
exciting stuff street fighter 5 not out
yet but when spring 2016 spring 2005 if
you're in a North America and you
preorder you can get access to our beta
that one starts in july twenty third
it's going to be an online beta test we
want to make sure that we have a
best-in-class online experience so want
to start testing that early in our
campaign so definitely preorder check
the game out july twenty third is the
start date adapt and is that pc and ps4
so the first one is exclusive to ps4 we
will be doing follow-up beta tests and
we will have a pc test later this fall
all right Matt gentlemen thank you guys
so much for coming on showing off some
skills and talking to street fighter 5
all right ladies and gents coming up
next it's delving into civilization got
a new expansion for beyond Earth they're
gonna be on stage momentarily